c'est une annonce qui ne passe pas pour
la communauté internationale en
relançant la production d'uranium
enrichi à 20%
l'iran s'est affranchi des restrictions
imposées par le traité de vienne
avec cette nouvelle procédure téhéran se
désengage un peu plus de cet accord une
décision qualifiée par les états unis de
chantage nucléaire est désapprouvée par
l'union européenne et israël
si cette annonce des autorités
iraniennes et mise en oeuvre elle
constituerait une entorse considérable
des avis des engagements nucléaires de
l'iran dans le cadre de l'accord de
vienne
c'est une violation flagrante et au
talent de ses engagements
il n'ya pas d'autre explication que
l'intention de l'iran de poursuivre la
fabrication d'armes nucléaires
je le répète israël ne permettra pas
l'iran de fabriquer des armes nucléaires
tu es revenu
les discussions autour du nucléaire
iranien se sont encore tendues en
novembre dernier après l'assassinât du
principal responsable scientifique du
programme nucléaire iranien selon
téhéran
cette attaque aurait été mise en oeuvre
par israël en réponse le parlement a
adopté une loi préconisant de produire
et de stocker au moins 120 kg d'uranium
enrichi à 20 % chaque année
samedi dernier les responsables de
l'organisation de l'énergie atomique ont
confirmé être prêt à lancer la nouvelle
procédure d'enrichissement
c'est le président qui devrait donner
les directives sur cette question
son premier ordre préliminaire a été
d'envoyer une lettre à l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique ce
que nous avons fait nous sommes telles
des soldats et nos doigts sont sur les
gâchettes le commandant doit commander
et nous nous tirons nous sommes prêts
pour cela et nous allons produire de
l'uranium enrichi à 20% dès que possible
dans ce contexte l'entrée en fonction de
joe biden à la maison blanche semble de
plus en plus urgente pour la question du
nucléaire iranien le président américain
élu souhaite préserver l'accord de
vienne mise à mal depuis que son
prédécesseur
on a retiré les états unis en mai 2018